huh son finally fulfilled his mission to
learn the fate of his father who never
returned from the Korean War Master
Sergeant Charles McDaniel went overseas
to fight nearly 70 years ago and after
human remains were recently returned to
the u.s. McDaniel was one of two missing
servicemen who was positively identified
you imagine well David Martin spoke to
his son in an interview you'll see only
on CBS this morning
David good morning good morning after
the Singapore summit with President
Trump
North Korea's Kim jong-un returned 55
boxes containing remains of Americans
killed in the Korean War that's a tiny
fraction of the 5,300 still missing and
doesn't sound like much until you find
out what it means to one family this
faded photo was one of the few memories
Charles McDaniel has of his father he
was just three years old when Master
Sergeant Charles McDaniel went off to
the Korean War and vanished without a
trace he disappeared from history I mean
he was just gone he wasn't dead he
wasn't a powa that was listed he was
gone he was a medic in an army battalion
overwhelmed by Chinese troops at the
Battle of unsung in North Korea on
November 2nd 1950 they lost 600 and some
people in one night they were basically
overrun that Chinese came in around them
surrounded them and then just over and
the battalion headquarters McDaniels
wife Gladys and their two sons never
knew what happened to him but when he
didn't come home with prisoners of war
he was officially declared dead a fact
which slowly registered with Charles as
he grew I remember all of a sudden as a
little boy starting to cry I was
inconsolable
he became an army chaplain and searched
military archives for his father's
service records but found no clues to
his faith then North Korea turned over
55 boxes of remains following the
Singapore summit 55 boxes come back
that's one percent of the missing in
action so I'm figuring at best there's a
1% chance that my
fathers remains of their but then as he
revealed at a ceremony in Hawaii
honoring the missing he got a call from
an army official he said why this is
amazing news for you we've got one dog
tag
one dog death
it's Abbas eaten away by rust but still
legible as my father's name on it his
blood type you don't know what happened
to your father exactly but you know it
could have been wearing that when he
died and probably was probably was with
a dog tag in hand it didn't take long
for the forensics lab in Hawaii to
identify McDaniels remains so they're
done DNA analysis they've done dental
analysis so it all adds up here's the
opinion established the remains as those
of Master Sergeant Charles Hobart
McDaniel right so that's me that's the
that's the definitive word that theme
right there yeah while they were in
Hawaii Charles and his younger brother
Larry asked for a moment alone with
their father's remains I just put my
hand on my father's skull head and said
a little thank-you prayer to God that
even to have this it's more than I ever
expected honestly I wouldn't ever use
the word lucky with your situation but
blessed is the word I would use but
fortunate God's grace is somehow allowed
this to happen Master Sergeant McDaniel
disappeared from history 68 years ago
but now he's found his remains will be
returned to his family in Indiana this
week for burial with full military
honors
yeah may he rest in peace and our thanks
to that entire family for their service
and dedication that 1% chance really
paid off David thank you